i've ordered a million paint by numbers
sets that's nice coloring so much i
like i never thought i'd be the girl
with adult coloring books but my kids
are coloring so much and i'm like okay
i'm done with princesses at this point
i've got to color something
else it's actually very therapeutic yeah
i i love doing it i was really into it
at the beginning and then i sort of
got out of it and now i think i'm gonna
dive back in
yeah i mean well there's only so much to
do when you're stuck in your house
can i see do you have anything can we
see anything
oh good i brought it i brought it in
case you wanted to see my
homework okay
dakota mine aren't looking at anything
like that
and dated in the corner yes very
professional
oh my gosh i'm not even kidding you i
was thinking like water maybe i'm an
idiot and still stuck in the 80s i was
thinking
you know watercolor things not like
this is actually by a a brand called
pink picasso and they're like
the fancy paint by number it's like
actually a canvas
and life level i know i can't
obviously it's all you know it's just
about filling in the little
no i can promise you if i did that girl
would not come out like that i'm not
that's not my kind of creativity i liked
it subscribe to my channel subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going